10dans de l'équateur rafael correa
condamné à huit ans de prison pour
corruption la peine est tombée
aujourd'hui l'ancien mardi l'ancien chef
de l'état équatorien qui vit désormais
en belgique est visée par une affaire
durant son mandat entre 2007 et 2017
rafael correa a dénoncé un mensonge avec
l'absence de preuves
il se dit être victime de persécution
politique avec la complicité des
magistrats écoutez son intervention
depuis bruxelles
quand bientôt ils ont tout changé tout
changer
regardez leurs principales preuves ils
nous ont montré l'un des fichiers qui se
trouvait sur l'ordinateur du conseiller
nous avons récupéré tous ses fichiers
avec une entreprise colombienne
nous avons prouvé qu'ils avaient été
piratés en 2016 est modifié avant 2018
c'est à dire que toutes les preuves ont
été complètement falsifiés ils n'ont pas
accepté ses preuves et il ne les
accepterons pas parce qu'ils ont peur
ils ont peur de connaître la vérité et
c'est pourquoi ils n'ont pas accepté
cette preuve hier je ne veux pas vous
ennuyer mais ils disent que j'ai reçu un
pot-de-vin de 1000 $ que je diriger un
groupe criminel
il y à une fuite de milliers de
documents qui confirmait ce scandale que
le parquet a été en contact permanent
avec le chef de juridiction
la secrétaire marc takahisa et le chef
de juridiction ivan les hommes ils ont
même été en couple je ne veux pas parler
de leur vie personnelle
mais il y a évidemment des passe-droits
et c'est à cause de cela que le juge a
été compromis le juge a été nommé le 12
février
ils ont amené cette jeune femme du
cotopaxi pour la nommer secrétaire le
1er mars
mais ils ont eu des factures
d'électricité de téléphone commune tout
est inversé cette affaire est une
collusion criminelle avec notamment
trafic d'influencé à des fins
mercantiles
cette procédure est une farce la fidi
air démontre encore une fois que la
décision pénale avait été préparé à
l'avancé
ils m'ont accusé de servir de médiateur
pour l'organisation de millau ils ont
passé une nuit sans dormir et ont
modifié la stratégie d'accusation il
s'avère maintenant que c'est une
complicité par provocation
il y a donc beaucoup de trous
d'incohérences dans l'accusation ils ont
d'ailleurs ajouter des circonstances
aggravantes violant ainsi tous les
principes de la faveur d'inspection il
nous condamne à huit ans de prison alors
que le code pénal prévoit un maximum de
cinq ans
colorisées maximum